D
ACCOUNTABLE, AND YOU CAN FIRE
THEM NEXT TUESDAY.
HERE WITH THE VERY LATEST FROM
WHAT WE CAN EXPECT ON TUESDAY
NIGHT, HE'S AT THE HEMMER BIG
BOARD, OUR VERY OWN BILL HEMMER
IS THERE.
BILL, GOOD TO SEE YOU ON THIS
FRIDAY NIGHT.
WE'LL BE WATCHING A LOT OF
RACES.
HERE'S WHAT I CONTEND.
TELL ME IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
THIS.
BY THE TIME ALL THE VOTES ARE
COUNTED, BETWEEN GEORGIA -- I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE SENATE
RACES -- NORTH CAROLINA, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO,
WISCONSIN, ARIZONA, NEVADA,
PROBABLY LESS THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND VOTES WILL DETERMINE
THE BALANCE OF POWER.
>> LIKE WHERE WE WERE IN 2020.
YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT ABOUT THAT,
SEAN.
WHAT I WANT TO DO FOR YOU --
>> Tucker: WE NEED YOU.
>> -- AND THE AUDIENCE TONIGHT
IS GIVE YOU A PRIMER ABOUT WHAT
YOU SHOULD LOOK FOR WHEN YOU
TUNE IN ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
I'M GOING TO TAKE YOU TO THE
HOUSE, SENATE, AND GOVERNOR
RACES, NOT THE WHOLE COUNTRY,
MOSTLY EASTERN TIME ZONES.
OKAY?
IN THE HOUSE, WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR A WHILE, IN THE
STATE OF VIRGINIA, CLOSES AT
7:00, THEY COUNT QUICKLY.
THESE ARE THE THREE HOUSE
DISTRICTS THAT SEEM TO BE THE
MOST HIGHLY CONTESTED.
IF REPUBLICANS ARE ABLE TO WIN
IN VIRGINIA, TOO, DOWN HERE IN
NORFOLK, THEN THEY'RE OFF TO A
DECENT START ON THE EVENING.
IF THEY'RE ABLE ALSO TO WIN IN
VIRGINIA AND DEFEAT ABIGAIL
SPANBERGER, RUNNING FOR A THIRD
TERM, SOUTH OF WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THEN YOU'LL START ASKING
YOURSELF HOW BIG IS IT WAVE.
IF THEY'RE ABLE TO WIN IN
VIRGINIA 10, WEST OF FAIRFAX
HERE, THEN YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ASK YOURSELF, HOW MANY FEET HIGH
IS IT.
ALL RIGHT?
BEFORE WE GO THERE, LET'S JUST
SAY THE DEMOCRATS HOLD ON TO
THESE SEATS, AND IF THAT'S THE
CASE, YOU'LL BE LOOKING FOR
OTHER AREAS ON THE EAST COAST.
REPUBLICANS ARE PLAYING IN
DISTRICTS THIS YEAR THAT YOU
WOULD NOT EXPECT.
JUST GOING TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE
RIGHT HERE.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME, SEAN,
YOU TALKED ABOUT RHODE ISLAND?
THIS IS THE WESTERN HALF OF
RHODE ISLAND THAT REPUBLICANS
REALLY LIKE THEIR CANDIDATE.
AND THE FORMER MAYOR OF
CRANSTON, THEY LIKE HIM, RUNNING
AN INTERESTING CAMPAIGN, AND
THEY SCORE A TRICK IN RHODE
ISLAND, THAT WOULD BE QUITE A
SWING.
CONNECTICUT, LIKE WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME, SEAN, YOU TALKED
ABOUT CONNECTICUT WHEN IT CAME
TO THE REPUBLICANS PARTY.
THE WESTERN HALF HERE IN
CONNECTICUT, GEORGE LOGAN,
REALLY GOOD CANDIDATE, TAKING ON
A CANDIDATE THAT'S HAD THE SEAT
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS, THEY
THEY'RE PLAYING IN THAT AREA AS
WELL.
FOR THE 7:00 CLOSING TIME, 8:00
CLOSING TIME, I WOULD THINK
ABOUT THE FIVE RACES THAT I JUST
MENTIONED THERE TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT
DEMOCRATS ARE HOLDING BACK
REPUBLICANS OR REPUBLICANS ARE
REALLY GETTING MOMENTUM.
THE OTHER THING IS DOWN HERE IN
FLORIDA.
A TON OF NEWS TUESDAY NIGHT ON
I WANT TO TAKE YOU FORWARD ONE
TIME HERE AND SHOW YOU WHAT I --
WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
THIS IS CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
27.
MARIA SALAZAR IS THE REPUBLICAN.
SHE LOST IN '18.
WON IN 2020.
SHE'S TRYING TO WIN RE-ELECTION
AGAIN.
SHE'S RUNNING DOWN HERE IN
MIAMI.
A LOT OF CUBAN AMERICANS.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS.
SHE DID IT IN 2020.
IF SHE'S ABLE TO RIDE THIS EARLY
WAVE OF VOTING, THE EARLY VOTE
IN FLORIDA, SEEMS TO SUGGEST
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE DOING
REALLY WELL SO FAR.
ALSO YOU'VE GOT THE BIG
GOVERNORS RACE.
THEN I'LL TAKE YOU INTO THE
SENATE RACE HERE.
WATCHING SALAZAR TO SEE HER
MARGIN FROM 2020, WHETHER SHE'S
ABLE TO MEET IT OR SURPASS IT.
THAT'S AN EARLY INDICATOR AS
WELL.
ON THE SENATE, THE OBVIOUS ONE,
RIGHT HERE, IT'S PENNSYLVANIA,
IT'S FETTERMAN AND OZ.
COULD GO LATE INTO THE NIGHT.
WE MAY NOT KNOW BASED ON MAIL-IN
BALLOTS.
WE MAY NOT KNOW TUESDAY NIGHT.
PENNSYLVANIA IS A BIG ONE.
NEW HAMPSHIRE IS OUT THERE.
OHIO WITH J.D. VANCE.
GEORGIA, THIS WARNOCK-WALKER
RACE.
GOT TO GET TO 50% TO AVOID A
RUNOFF DECEMBER 6th.
THAT'S FROM HOT, AND CLOSE AT
7:00 AS WELL.
ONE MORE AREA, THE GOVERNOR
RACES, SOME GOOD ONES TOO.
I WOULD THINK ABOUT 9:00 CLOSING
TIME IN NEW YORK, IS LEE ZELDIN
REALLY CONTENDING AGAINST
HOCHUL?
IF HE IS, THERE WILL BE SUSPENSE
FOR THAT, NOT JUST THAT, BUT
HOUSE RACES WE'RE TRACKING AS
WELL.
YOU GOT TWO GREAT RACES, CAN
BRIAN KEMP DEFEAT STACEY ABRAMS
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN FOUR
YEARS?
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE WATCHING
AS WELL.
RON DESANTIS RUNNING AGAINST
CHARLIE CRIST.
WATCH THE MARGIN ON THE OUTCOME
OF THIS RACE.
THAT WILL TELL US A LOT ABOUT
THIS ELECTION NECK TUESDAY.
IT MIGHT TELL US A LOT ALSO
ABOUT THE NEXT ELECTION IN '24.
SEAN, BACK TO YOU.
>> Tucker: BILL HEMMER, GREAT
ANALYSIS.
IT'S THE HEM